テヤァァァァァァ
トンッ(段ボールをたたく音)
～開封の舞～（汚い）
フゥッ！
柿の種
みなさん柿の種って知ってるかい？
柿の種って
なんなんですかぁ
KAKIでもないしぃTANEでもなぁい（ドヤぁ ）
そんな何でもない柿の種一粒あたりが
すごい小さいんですよ
私はぁぁ思ってしまいましたぁ
柿の種だったら
むぅげんにたぁべられるう
柿の種こそほんとに無限に食えます
だって小さいもん
一粒あたりのサイズがもうほんっ薄っぺらすぎて
ないんで
もう食べても誤差なんで無限に食べれると思いまして
今回柿の種
準備いたしました
とりあえず全部出します！！！！
やばい
ざーーーーーーーーーーーーーー（出す音）
威圧感がすごい威圧感が
ああああ
やばいやばい
こぼれそうこぼれそう
やばいやばいやばいばい
すまんみんな
あと５袋残ってるんですけど限界なんで
とりあえずこの量食べます
(保険)
僕の体重は
自分の体重の六分の一も食えるわけねぇよ
パァロロロ
とりあえず無理なのはわかってるんですけども
突然皆さん無茶ぶりで
先輩とか恋人とか親に
柿の種たくさん食べろって言われたら
どれくらいが限界かわかんないじゃないですか
その参考例として
今日は検証していこうと思います
参考にまでに皆さん見て行ってくださいね☆
ではいただきます！
0124mex
わたくしが持てる力をすべて使わせていただきます
（ちびちび食べる）
あっ
うまい
うまいうまい
いや一粒一粒が小さいんで
待って辛いな
はい！(挙手)
100粒食べました
食べてみた感想なんですけど
おなかは全然食べれます(パワーワード)
全然余裕
ただ
なんかめっちゃ辛い
なにこれ(柿の種です)
サクッ
なんでこんな辛いんや
ちょっと柿の種が意味わからな過ぎて
ちょっと調べます
てことは元をたどればお米なのかな？
yeah
食います
どんどん行きましょう
はい200粒食べました
おなかは全然ダイジョブなんですけど
ほんととてつもなく辛いです
しゃべってても舌が痛いくらい辛いんですけど
おなかはまだ全然いけるんで
ちょっと苦しみながらも食べていこうと思います
オナシャス
はぁいぃ
300粒食いました
はっふう…
頑張ります(小声)
ｳﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞ
ｳﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞ
ｲﾀﾞｲ
ｲﾀﾞｲﾖｫﾞｫﾞ
うわあ↑
ああ痛
やばい
やばい手汗が止まんない汗が焦りの汗がやばい
ｫﾞｫﾞｫﾞｫﾞｫﾞｫﾞ
やっぱこれがないと無理や
ピーナッツ:私が来た！
あはは(小声)
うん
ｪｪｪﾔﾊﾞｧｧｧｨｶﾗｨｶﾗｨからい！
やばい！
サクッ
ドサァッ
やばい×８
はい！(挙手)
勢いで700粒まで来ました
びっくりしたポイントはピーナッツと一緒に食べると
辛さが全く無くなりました
びっくり(小並感)
やっぱ柿ピーてのはすごい味覚的においしいことが
証明されたおつまみなんだなって思いました
おなかが結構
どんどん行きましょぉぉう！
画面のそっちでわかんないと思うんすけど
柿の種さぁ
ごめんなさい動画外ですごい今めっちゃ苦労してます
ｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞ
やばい、、
柿の種に対してピーナッツが少なすぎる
現在の投票率は以下のようになっております
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
ｼｬｧﾞｧﾞｧﾞ！
(これなんだろ、、、)
(つまんなそ)
ポイッ
やばい、、、
もう食えない
ドンドンドドンドン
いやもう無理だってぇ
いやいや無理無理多すぎる多すぎる
ドンドンドドンドン
いやこれ以上食ったら危ないってぇ
食うけど！？
ドンドンドドンドン
ドンドンドン
食うけど！？
ドンドンドンドン
ドンドンドンアァドン
食うけど！？
ドンドンドドンドン
アンアンアアンアン
ふぅ(フクロウみたいな声)
はいというわけですいません
死力を尽くしましたが
本気で柿の種を食うと
約1560粒ほど食べることができました
あと辛い！！
ピーナッツないとマジできつい
ということがわかりました
皆さん突然誰かに柿の種食べさせられそうになったら
まぁだいたい1300、1400くらいでやめておいたほうが
いいのだと思いました
みんなぁぁぁぁ
エンディング
はじめ)ドンドンドドンドン
けんすけ)いや無理だよさすがに俺一人じゃあ
はじめ)けんすけドンドンドドンドン
いやさすがに無理だって
はじめ)ドンドンドドンドン
けんすけ)さすがにのめんのめん
けんすけ)さすがにはじめさん一人じゃ無理だよ
けんすけ)ドンドンドドンドン
はじめ)やめっっｗ
けんすけ)ｗｗｗ